welcome to sin city chronicles let's
start this week with one of the biggest
fights in boxing history julio cesar
chavez and hector camacho that flight
fight took place on september 12 1992 at
the thomas and mac 19
566 fans filled the arena it sold out in
less than 36 hours and was the largest
indoor boxing crowd in nevada history
chavez won by unanimous decision did you
know that las vegas had horse racing it
was this week back in 1953 that the las
vegas park opened the 20 000 seat track
was only open for 13 days bankruptcy
internal scandal and lack of crowd
forced it to close and there were some
design flaws as well on opening night it
took one hour to get into the track that
kind of sounds familiar they eventually
turned the horse track into a racing
track and held one nascar race in 1955.
the land was later sold to build the las
vegas convention center las vegas
country club in the international hotel
you can kind of see the track there in
the background let's talk now about the
king
[Applause]
elvis performed
636 sold out shows at the international
hotel and he passed away in 1977 on
september 8 1978 the iconic bronze
statue of elvis inside the international
hotel was unveiled priscilla presley and
that's elvis father vernon they were on
hand for the unveiling the statue was
originally outside before moving into
the lobby and then the international
hotel is now called the westgate
on september 9 2007 the mtv video music
awards were held at the palms britney
spears was the opening act performing
her single give me more but the buzz of
the night took place off stage when pam
anderson's two ex-husbands got tommy lee
in kid rock well they got into a fight
and according to tmz tommy got it pretty
bad and kid rock was cited for
misdemeanor battery the 2021 vmas they
take place this thursday that's your sin
city chronicles for the second week of
september thank you jc always fun all
right